all right misty
yes misty where'd you go where are you
from from charleston west virginia
charleston west virginia yes i've been
there
tell me about your uh your family
growing up you had mom and dad
yeah um
uh
yeah i was like i live me and my brother
live with my mom and dad
but i have a i have a half sister but
she grew up with my grandparents and
stuff
but
like uh but
like
everything was okay until like i turned
13 or so like when we moved to a
different city and everything
like that's when i i guess you know like
kind of separated from everyone like
kind of kind of like left home at a
really young age you know why'd you
leave so young um me my dad never really
got along like um
it was like uh
my mom like she just tried to get better
for me all the time but like you know it
just meant close problems between her
and him
but like we didn't get along at all like
it was like a bad thing you know like
but then like he ended up um
ended up getting too bad and everything
and that left you know like
they didn't really say nothing about it
or nothing like that you know
like uh i was staying with um
this guy i was dating which who i ended
up being with for like eight years um
he ended up is he the father of my
daughter's of my daughter she's not
but um
we were just staying from place to place
and that's really when i started doing
like
you know i started in the drugs and
stuff like um
like i went kind of like went from
marijuana and stuff and like
like the other stuff which is mostly
crystal at first
and then like after um i was with tim
for like
uh until my daughter was six months old
and he beat on me a lot so like
whenever like whenever she turns two
months old
uh
he went he got arrested or something uh
like uh i think he stole a car or
something like uh but i think yeah he
stole the car with the baby in it and he
got arrested for a while she like i was
able to leave him and stuff then i was
just meeting my daughter
and i kind of had like um
a room at a hotel that i was paying for
a lot i was probably like
i was six months so i was like 16. um
after that like
how old were you when you had your your
daughter i was 15 15.
and i had a right before 2016.
i ended up having my son uh
or getting pregnant with my son like not
too long afterwards and having him right
before turn 18.
which um his father passed away um
but
after i got with my son's father
uh
i kind of stayed with him and his
grandparents for a little while
uh
but me and him like really we split up
for like maybe a couple months and
everything and he ended up
well before i get to that part
he's the one that introduced me to
heroin
and uh
uh i wasn't really bad on it then you
know
but
we split up for a little bit and he
ended up overdosing off off of it
and that's kind of when i went off the
deep end that's how he died
yeah
and um after
after that happened i kind of like
my kids like i was like my mom and dad
like
like
watch my daughter a lot and
my son he was with his uh
his father's uh grandparents a lot you
know
but like
um a family of friends of mine like were
like trying to take custody of my
daughter and everything which they
succeeded and stuff
after that like
after that i kind of lost my rights and
stuff because i was
so far gone on the um heroin that was
like harder for me to get off of it you
know
so i couldn't like keep up with the drug
tests or nothing like that to keep my
kids
so kind of lost every like all that and
like at one time
but ever since then like i've been like
i haven't been away from like
the heroine and stuff like
i was using the needle since i was 14.
you know like i started using that when
i was on crystal
but like
i've been like struggling to get away
from it since then but
it's really hard
so the
you're currently doing fentanyl then
fentanyl yeah yeah you're smoking it or
you're injecting it uh
well
kind of both right now that's what i was
trying to get away from is injecting it
that's all i used to do you know
but um i wanted to get away from a
period coming out here you know
my parents moved out here first with my
brother
and like two years ago um i was staying
with this guy in march well
i was staying with him for about a month
or so but
it's a little bit crazy though like he
would stay up for like so many days and
everything
i ended up um getting an accident where
like what one accident like
he shot me five times with a 22 revolver
and uh
like i got a picture or something i'll
show you maybe afterwards and [ __ ] i
don't i'm not bad sorry excuse my
language he shot you yeah five five
times with 22 over um the first one went
through my hand like right here and you
probably can't see it on the camera but
another metal plate from where i like
shattered my bone
and it came out right there um the other
one
and then went in my arm right there
there's a little tiny bullet so you
can't really you can't see them up close
i mean far away though and came out
right there and this one's still in here
i got one right here and the one in my
spine it came out three months later
that's the one i have a picture of
sticking like halfway on my back that's
crazy and then i got one in the back of
my arm what were the circumstances that
he shot you over i was leaving and the
same that same day earlier that day we
got into a huge fight he had been up for
like 24 days like not like maybe cat nap
here and there but he was losing his
mind like so he was like
yeah he would beat on me non-stop but we
were still over stuff that wasn't even
it didn't even sound like it could be
true you know like made up stuff like
people hiding in the walls and stuff it
was crazy like but like
that's the whole reason that
i moved out here the first time i was
out here
which was about like
um
maybe uh
okay well it's been about like three
years all together now so like i was out
here for eight months
in that three-year period and then i
went back home to um
i had missed court already so i don't
think he likes doing time or anything
for he did a year maybe but i was out
here when the court date happened
but um and i
i hope hopefully i never see him again
but like he was a boyfriend or a pimp or
both
no he was just somebody i was buying
drugs off about staying with
i never really had a pimp i did escort
when i was back home
never off work for anybody or nothing
like that i did on my own online
but when i came out here i kind of like
try to get away from that because i
don't want to like i wanted to start
over you know i don't want people to
like
judge me for certain things anymore um
i'm actually kind of scared to do it out
here period you know because it's a lot
more dangerous here than it is out there
you know so how are you surviving now
um
and like
i say like most of the time i have like
i have my friend michael that which is
um he's a he's a truck driver i actually
met him through escorting from back home
he helps me out when i don't have like
that much stuff like
then if not like i'm usually
borrowing money that i usually can't pay
back um
just uh little things like selling
things or like you know come like coming
up on things like
stupid stuff like i haven't like
i've been offered to do that a couple
times but like
i'm so like the people i hang around
like you know they talk a lot you know
like so i'm too scared to do this like i
was scared to do this you know because i
don't want a lot of people know my past
you know
but you know
it's hard to talk about it you know
your family is where now
um my mom my dad and my brother they
stay in hollywood and they got like a
little so they're local they could help
you
yeah but they're well i forgot to add
that and i skipped too much
they're on drugs as well so like they're
like they're in a studio apartment that
has no bedrooms and all three of them
are staying there
and my mom
my mom's the only one that's normal
there like but she's not
she's finally going to school and to be
a nurse and stuff but
my dad and my brother they're like
they're
they're like kids and they are you over
everything and it's bad are you like
almost fist fighting are you in non-stop
they bring like my mom's almost lost
their apartment because they won't clean
they like
bring junk and bikes and all kinds of
crazy stuff in there and like
and when i'm there it's just
there's nowhere to sleep there you know
like there's nowhere to go
and i do like try to help my mom when i
got it you know like she can't barely
help me they like
oh they're just living off ssi right now
until she's done with schooling you know
because my dad won't work he thinks he
don't have to work because he gets to
stop ssi and i don't think
well me and my my family knows it and i
know you know like he's not all the way
there you know it's like he like
it's like he stopped at a certain age
you know like
and it's like hard you know stuff like
that so i don't stay there like i just
now had to go the reason i had to leave
and come back here is because um
i had uh
i was supposed to pay 120 on the room i
was staying there but
i only had like uh
like
20 and i had to put it in gas to go
back there and over there over here but
she was telling me about this you know
like
nah like
and um i was kind of worried about it
you know she was like all you have to do
is talk about like you know
um like what you went through and stuff
like that and it's really easy you know
like
i was like it might be easy like it's
not
at the same time it's not you know
and now like i have like
i don't really have nowhere like i'm
going like a state like i stay at like
you know like the underground casino
sometimes but i don't have anywhere to
go i'll stay there because they're open
like all night you know
just can't sleep there and i'm like that
you know
and right now i'm moving off and you
know like what people help me out with
you know like sometimes over there like
they'll give you like a little bit of
money or like
to offer you food and stuff they help
you over there a little bit but not as
much as you need you know
and your kids are aware now
um my daughter
the family friends i was telling you
about well supposed friends i guess i
signed up and tried to sign my custody
over to my dad before it happened but
they ended up winning because my mom and
dad went together time and he was
working at the time so he wasn't able to
watch her by himself
so they got full custody of her i ended
up losing my rights a couple months
later and
they changed her whole full name and
they even got the cps to
make it to where my grandparents weren't
even allowed to go around um my daughter
because she would cry when they leave
and um and it was uh wasn't it good for
her or something
but she was seven years old when they
changed their full name which i think
was wrong but you know
so you haven't seen your kids then two
yeah two years yeah
how old do you know
i'm i'm 25. you're 25.
yeah and um
like uh the shooting happened when i was
23.
um
what are you afraid of now what do you
worry about
right
or like
not being able to like
i hate the fact that
my kitten
sorry
but
my son
like my baby dad my fault my son's
father
he um he like raised both my kids with
me like well he was more of a father
than her father
but like when
i kind of hate myself for like
lying like making them the world neither
of them have either of their parents
you know
the only thing i don't worry about every
day it's like if something were to
happen and i wouldn't be there you know
or something would have happened to me
because of what i do
and like
it hurt them you know like i just wanted
to get better you know
have you tried to get clean
i haven't really been in obs yet like
i just keep thinking like when i do go
to rehab or something like when i do get
out
i don't have no one that i could go to
my my my family like they still don't
join so i couldn't go to that middle
and uh
i know where i just moved out here like
a year ago um
i don't i don't really know that many
people that could help me and all the
people i do know are when i'm so
but like out here i've thought there's a
better chance for rehab because like
their rehabs aren't like prisons
back where i'm from their rehabs they're
like jealous and they're so you know
like
i've seen a couple of the ones out here
and they look like i can like they're
easier to you know right
is this the lowest point of your life
right now
i'd say right before i moved out here
was but yeah probably the close it's not
nowhere and that's not any better but
it's not worse you know
i guess it's yeah
same
but
i don't
i don't know like
i want i know like most of my friends
i've already passed away from doing the
same thing i do
and uh
and like i hear like i don't hear much
people doing it the way i do it out here
but like everybody where i'm from that's
all they do you know like that's the
only thing out there is like yeah in
west virginia yeah that's the only thing
where you're from yeah it's a lot of
control there yeah it's
yeah like that's why i started as a
junior agent because everybody you know
like
it's everywhere out there were all your
all your friends doing it at that time
yeah everybody i know out there doesn't
you know like it's crazy like
when like
i like i always thought that you know
i didn't even i didn't even finish
school you know like i got to
when i said well i was 13
i had trinity for like three years and
uh
i like
well the only reason i didn't get locked
up and my parents get locked up because
i got pregnant during that time you know
and they gave me like you know they like
looked over a little bit you know
but i kind of like stopped going like
ninth grade
like beginning of ninth grade completely
you know
you know
i don't have no e gedm no one got my ged
yet you know
my i did have my license i got it when i
had um when i was with my son's father
before i split up but um
i ended up getting a couple a few
tickets and then
and now i'd expire and then everyone got
it renewed so like
uh i kind of lost it you know like
i don't have a social or anything now
because my everything in mind usually
gets stolen because i have to leave it
places like
carrying around the stuff that i have
with me it's like tiring you know so
like i'll leave it somewhere or get
stolen
or i won't be able to go back and get it
you know
and it's just hard you know i've been
trying to like for the past like i think
it was eight days
um i've had um my friend michael and
from back home he's helped me out with
the room but
he's not he's not doing the work he used
to do because his heart's uh
not this way it was it used to be so
like you don't make nowhere near as much
money so he can't pay for it all the
time you know
so like after that like i usually just
like
stay from my friends or like somebody i
know or
try to go there for a couple days and
you're staying down in south central l.a
yeah i was at king's castle motel where
do you stay now just forever
just here and there but i wasn't staying
there a lot i was just there for like
eight years if you're in south central
yeah already girls like yourself are
gonna end up yeah i know i was the first
time i was ever done that that way but
other than being at the
uh 33rd street you know because that's
where the tap tap is you know
where the casino
but um
that's the only reason i was that down
that way i usually stay in hollywood but
you know like close to where i could
like if i needed to i could call my mom
or my dad you know like
even though they wouldn't they don't
answer half the time so what are your
plans now for your future
you know yeah i want to get my kids back
you know
i don't want them to like i don't want
to miss their
like them growing up all the way like
already missed a good bit you know
like my daughter like i seen a couple
pictures online because they don't let
me see pictures of her or nothing the
people that adopted her after i lost my
rights which is the people that i've
known my whole life but
with your
with the families that have your kids
give them up if you got clean
i don't well my sons
yes because he's with his uh his
father's family
they want they wanted me to get clean
and stuff like that you know but
they never really helped or nothing like
that i never really
but they do like his sister i know she's
like watches after my son a
sends me pictures of him and stuff but
my daughter the ones that have my
daughter where they have two different
dads you know
but like um
her dad
like he's a
he's on drugs he's never really been in
her life at all since like i said
but um
never even cared to be in her life you
know but
uh he instantly signed his rights over
when i lost mine so but they i don't
think they will like you know and i
heard that you have to have their
permission
if they've been adopted out you know
like i read about that that's what
scared me more than anything because
like
like i
feel like that's the only thing that
stopped me from like actually like going
to get clean because i feel like
there's no possible way i would be able
to get her back you know
because like
it's like um
the son of the girl the woman that
adopted um my daughter
is like my dad's best friend okay
but he's also like a real big pervert
and like he'd always want me to hang out
with them and stuff but i never dated
him or like i want to date him and i
never wanted to you know
and like
they feel like that's like more of a
hatred towards me you know
why like you know i would never be able
to you know
or why they did what they did you know
and like they told my dad that once that
once i saw my rights over once he got
the temporary custody that they were
gonna you know back off they weren't
gonna go quarterback they were just
worried about her
and where i was always gone and stuff
and he was watching her
if they were just worried about it but
they didn't back off and he ended up
losing her uh well he they ended up
getting right you know getting in there
full custody but i haven't seen her
since then like i also like i didn't get
to say goodbye to her you know um
because the morning they went to court i
wasn't supposed to be around her at the
time because i already saw my rights
over to my dad i mean on my rights but
my
custody
and like um i'm waking up that morning
and i'm brushing her hair and then i
actually just got there the night before
because i was out running the streets
you know
and
and i regret every minute of not you
know
of not being there you know
i didn't think that
that could happen that fast you know
if you if you had your life to do all
over again misty what would you have
done differently
and
i definitely would have never tried any
kind of drugs this first year like i
would
would have finished school and i would
have listened you know when
back in charleston what what percentage
of the kids you were in school with
the state stayed away from drugs
[Music]
i i couldn't tell you i really don't
know a lot of them that stayed away from
a lot of them
because i i did think a lot of them did
stay away from a while but after i would
go back
because i was staying in charleston at
the time but i'm from elkl okay so like
but when i went back to oakview i would
see everybody was on like the like i
went back for a little while before i
moved out here maybe a month or so
uh from who died here the last time and
everybody i knew from school was like
doing drugs too really i was hearing
things about and i didn't even know they
were on them you know like i think
oakview was the worst spot for me to end
up at like before i went there
i was like a cheerleader like i was a
cheerleader i had like i never smoked a
cigarette i never did nothing like that
you know
i ended up just hanging out with the
wrong people and at a young age
and not knowing what they were i didn't
know what methamphetamines was at the
time i didn't know what
heroin was when i started doing it you
know
i just knew that people were doing it
that i was hanging out with
and they said it's okay you know you
like it you know try
you know and i want to you know fit in
so you know that's like what most people
do you know
but i didn't even hear about them before
i started doing them you know so i
didn't even know what i was doing when i
started
were there things you wanted to do with
your life before you got involved in
drugs yeah i wanted i wanted to be a
veterinarian um
i had uh when i had uh
i got cleaned for like
two months
i think was the longest that would have
well no
i take that back as when i was with my
my son's father for about eight months
all we did was smoke weed but
when i had both my kids over there um
his grandparents um
i think right when we broke up is right
when everything
went real real bad you know like because
she didn't have done a couple months
later and
i ended up losing my kids right around
that same long time
and uh
it just like i just went
i went deeper into that life you know
like i didn't want to be
and i want to stop and think about
things you know i just wanted to stay
moving or stay doing stuff so i wouldn't
think about it you know
and uh and like right now that's what
happened that's what i'm i'm still
trying to like
and that's what i still do honestly like
i try not to say sit or think about it
you know
because i hurt you
to not just to not have my kids like me
like
to know that i've i'm running my
problems and i've
i've never lived a normal life yet you
know
do you blame
growing up where you grew up or your
family or both through your situation
now i just i know it's my fault too you
know
my mom tried to keep me from doing
stupid stuff like that you know and she
did they did keep it from me my brother
until like a certain age that from from
us to so we're snooping you know like
that they didn't that they did this we
didn't know about it until like until
around that area until we got to oakview
and stuff
that's when they would have like more
people over my house was kind of like a
trap house at that point you know when i
was 13 you know
and like um
i think it was because they got they got
on um methamphetamines around that time
they were just doing pills beforehand i
guess when i was
in saint albans um
but um
that's when my brother started noticing
you know like
like my dad wasn't well my dad was
working but he wasn't he wasn't keeping
jobs
and they were arguing a lot and like it
was just bad it mean my dad
like
i'm like i always tried to take up for
him like if my mom were working with him
and but like
it's like no matter how hard i tried
like i was like he like
he never noticed or like he like hated
me for some reason but like when i
turned 21 or no 20 i think i was 20
years old um
my mom started dating this one guy when
in between there like a little breakup
named allen and she's like and then i
got a message from my dad one day
saying that
he read some of the messages from my
mom's facebook to him saying that
he that
she
that was a possibility that he that alan
god was my dad you know
but my dad was telling me this to act
like he didn't know you know then my mom
told me he already knew that that was a
possibility
so i feel like that's why my dad held so
much anger towards me and not my brother
yeah like i feel like he just never
thought i was his you know
and still this day like every day like
no matter how bad we argue no matter
how bad he hurts me like i can't love
them you know
it's just hard because i care too much
about everything
and some people walk all over me like
crazy like
i don't have it to give and i still give
it you know
i don't know i'm just like
i'm a cancer too it's a very sensitive
and things you know like so like i don't
like arguing people in confrontation you
know and i hear there's a lot of it you
know
especially in the crowd to hang out with
misty what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
listen to people when they tell you
don't take life for granted i guess you
know
because it couldn't even end any minute
or you could
you don't know what you have until you
lost it you know
and don't do drugs obviously
all right misty thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck with
thank you getting clean and maybe
getting your kids back thank you thank
you
you